guys it's great to see you all again
Optima ting at Fright Fest now for
anyone who doesn't quite know about the
world the twisted twins and doesn't know
what to expect
let's give them an idea now you guys in
the past have compared yourselves to
lars von trier and Joss Whedon who is
who and why is that
I am Joss Whedon and she's also Janne is
Lars and of course the silve herself and
it's because I like to put the heart
into things and she likes to take it out
and then take a crap on it
not literally artistically and a
beautiful shot okay I'm I'm the optimist
I'm hoping for a better world
even in the face of you know a lot of
negativity and she is just like that's
crap honest to God if she didn't exist
no one would watch the movie today like
I wouldn't cut my wrists afterwards and
with her because of her it's like oh I
can bear this oh sure it's something
terrible and then I'll be like oh god I
have to be really fun eNOS no the only
reason I think this film has that light
and it's because of these two women
beside me Katie and I Jen because they
brought so much warmth and light into
something that was so unforgivingly
darker remember I had my mom read the
scriptures I call my cot I was like no
it's okay Jenna can you make it it'll be
bearable that is Katie shoes are a
little beacon of light yeah everybody
Justin ray of sunshine ha ha ha but
speaking of Katie now I know you're
caught you're obviously an actress but
you've also grown up on film sets and
another why haven't you could both your
parents of film ease so you've got lots
of experience on films that's how did it
compare being on a film set with Jen and
Sylvia here I'll be nice sweetie okay
nothing in the world great compares to
being just around these two in general
um and on set there they're on fire all
the time and on set they're just up in
flames and they they're confusing in
that in that you don't know how they
community I mean obviously they're twins
and they sit next to each other that
commute with the communicate so well and
they'll have little twin fights every
once a while they'll be they'll bicker
for one second to go hang on a minute
then go into a corner and go
okay and then it will all be resolved in
jujitsu like this is fascinating
everyone on the whole crew would
basically do anything for them they
would lay down in front of a train for
these two and not when you're on a show
and everyone especially a low-budget
movie like this where everyone's you
know volunteering or working for barely
any money it helps when you have these
two personalities that really rally
everybody and everyone puts their entire
heart does absolutely anything they can
to get it done at the end of the day and
it was a real it was a real family or
community effort was a lovely wonderful
and smiles rainbows isn't it that's very
diplomatic will work with you thank you
you're like a girl we literally because
everybody who came on board it would
definitely wasn't for the money we had
15 days to shoot it with a very modest
budget it's part of our massive loan
scam and it's working everybody came on
like they bring stuff from home they
were just so excited I think that's why
the movie is what it is cuz you see that
in every frame that everybody just went
all out everybody cared yeah you don't
get that too much I mean how many sets
I'm like so what's this movie about
they're like oh it's crap oh is that
literally yeah you're kind of my kind
now I know America mo was inspired by
your experiences in the movie industry
Chan and Sylvia so spill hi um was
amazed when I found out the stereotype
about the classic Hollywood producer was
real I was surprised but some of the
things that would be said around
Jennifer and I and then when we got into
independent horror it was almost like
coming home and we used mainstream
medicine and body-mod is an analogy for
that but we we've been acting not really
successfully since we were seven this
one has seen so much more [ __ ] than we
could have ever so we're both proudly
failed actresses we're also failed
models filled promotion girls being in
the entertainment industry there are
those incidents where you know you're at
an audition they're like okay well I'm
gonna have to you know see those now
it's like no no you're not going to see
these right now these are
me agree them I look at them not you
know it's writ cuz we would do body
doubling to like gent gents almost a few
people's asses and it's like it is it
can be late it can be a very
professional thing or it can be like all
the guys that work on set come and look
at your ass and like so sear it does a
group really make this decision is that
oh so they're oh yeah I've been on sets
we're like people from other sets we're
coming over and it's like well I'm
flattered but okay it's nice to have
that experience because I'm when we do
do something with a sexuality in
uncomfortable situations which we do a
bit in American marry we made sure it
was professional everyone felt
comfortable so they could do that not
like okay guys everyone come over here
someone's gonna be naked it's like no no
guys it's professional it's just if it's
a dick everyone's neither has one or a
seen one before them in life or it's a
few years off from say one of a
mainstream Hollywood we use the the
medical profession and it seems a lot of
times especially in Hollywood the people
that are really well respected and the
people that are seen as like the a-list
guys can be such sleaze bags and so
misogynistic and that is why you know
you have those stories like that with
dead hooker in a trunk it was on a much
smaller scale so we didn't come up to
that as much but with American marry
especially as we were trying to sell
American marry and get it made it was
just the same crap over and over again
yeah everyone that one question was like
so when's Mary's tits coming out of like
oh and why would that happen really
because it would be hot as like haha no
you need a little better whatever
diggities it needs a reason Katie how
does it compare for you as well in terms
of an experience because they've just
told me all about their experiences um I
think growing up because both my parents
were filming um my parents are very
clued into you know what can happen what
can be exploited on set and they knew
everybody and I I grew up in Vancouver
film um and everyone knew me I was a kid
you know they were there my family that
raised me um so no one no one messed
with me as I was well taken care of and
well protected I Teamsters and grips
raised me and and looked after me and
they still do to this day
it's all this extension it's taking
family that that will look after me and
I I you know I'm fairly good at keeping
myself out of odd situations my [ __ ]
radar is fairly well tuned and I'm a bit
of a [ __ ] myself so no anything over on
me
I don't come across is completely
innocent and doe-eyed I don't think so
no I don't like people look at me hello
there's what we can find people yeah I
lied sure about you now America Mary
you've described it as being like an
opera tell me more well I feel sometimes
when people are making horror movies
they almost make it like porn in the
respect that like we don't need story or
characters or anything as long as
there's tits and blood it's fine and up
and that's not why I got into the genre
I love kind of like more interesting
stories and I was like what if we showed
people that you can have something in
that genre but make it really good and
really pretty to watch and have more of
a journey of you seeing this character
that's the kind of a mix between the
antagonist and the final girl and half
everything that she goes through I feel
largely with North American horror they
see hores just like the slasher films or
the horror remakes and where you look at
world cinema like a lot of Europeans in
a moment we're in Europe I always forget
that when I'm in Asian cinema things
like Let The Right One In and I saw the
devil and one of our favorite directors
is Takashi Miike and they asked him
what's it like to be a horror movie
director and he's like I'm not a horror
movie director I make a great film and I
try to put horrific elements in that and
I think [ __ ] kind of does escape
definition I think that it shouldn't be
paint-by-numbers horror
yeah but Dad forced us to see a lot of
operas growing up too if you watch it
it's it's got a lot of it's like a
modern tragedy I think a lot of things
you watch it like oh but don't know if
you haven't seen that don't pay
attention to what I said I don't know
what happens to nosy phones is there big
it's another happily ever after from you
know of us yeah exactly
now Casey when we spoke last time you
talked about being a bit of a chicken
and you get bit skirted quite easily so
how is it filming some of the more out
there scenes in the film
I'm fine being on set and doing our own
movies I don't like other I don't like
horror movies I just totally in fact
they affect me in ways that later on I'm
walking through an underground parking
lot with high heels on my hands are
clicking and I'm convinced someone's
chasing me to get to the door and I'm
trying to jam the key and Ipana get her
here again and I finally return around
I'm like like doing yo he done it I know
and I'll be walking through the woods
I'll hear a snap I'm like [ __ ] that's
how movies I get killed in start I don't
level I might there's enough of that I'm
already completely delusional myself I
don't need to watch other horror movies
to scare the crap out of me um I just I
get all upset and tense and on set is
fine I know everybody everyone's there
everyone knows me ORS tons of blood and
I'm yelling at Jason to stop scribbling
my face and like that's all fine it's
just other people's movies I don't know
what's gonna jump out of where when yeah
I like alien I like jaws like classic
car reviews like butter you know I love
tricking you not soon Thank You shun
that was not gonna go metal in it I
could sell her as what they qin let's
Lena Gomez be in a movie that was
violinist my brother and I and your
mother the three of us were clinging
together shaking horrified to get over
that for like hours days I hadn't seen
it before head right here we should have
known it got to a point where it's like
oh I feel really there's this one that
18 I was like dude I just looked over
and everyone's horrified was a guy and
she leaned over she's like I'm so sorry
and then she pinned you down to the
chair wouldn't let you need is rating
they serve wine unless here guys it's
been great to talk to you again loads of
look with American married at all and
with the DVD release as well in great
sweetie take care your pleasure
you